welcome to an emergency shop show
hot takes because our boy jake paul has
announced that tommy fury once again has
pulled out of the freaking fight
and jake paul released a scathing video
to let us know that our friend tommy
fury has pulled out let's see what he
had to say yet again i wake up this
morning to another text to my manager
saying that tommy fury is pulling out of
the fight we agreed to all of the terms
everything is ready to go we're 45 days
away from the fight we agreed to his two
million dollar purse we agreed about a
testing extra flights extra rooms extra
tickets to the fight we're scheduled to
have a press conference next week in new
york his whole entire team was like yeah
everything's good we're signing the
contract today today it kept on getting
pushed it kept on getting pushed till
now what's the excuse
oh i can't comment i can't do it because
my dad can't be there with me during the
fight well tommy your dad has been
banned from the united states for 15
years you've known this the whole entire
time he's a criminal he's not allowed in
when he fought anthony taylor in
cleveland neither tyson nor your dad
were there with you in your u.s debut
and now all of a sudden you need your
team with you that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense i will agree to not have
my team around me during the fight week
i will agree
to not fight with my coaches in my
corner we could both fight solo dolo
just like devin haney was going to do
against george cambosos this is what
real boxers do this is what real boxers
they make fights [ __ ] happen you're
scared you claim you're a professional
boxer but you don't want to make the
fight with me
who you've talked so much [ __ ] about or
you said you will spark will you say i'm
nothing compared to you
where's all that [ __ ] talk now tommy
you're a [ __ ] atypical professional
boxer who doesn't want to make this
fight actually [ __ ] happen this is
the biggest opportunity of your [ __ ]
life and you're fumbling the [ __ ] bag
once again and i can't believe how
[ __ ] stupid you are
[ __ ] idiot
now this is the second time tommy fury
has pulled out a fight with jake paul
and it's pretty obvious tommy fury does
not want this fight his excuse is his
dad nor his brother can corner him in
the fight but he's fought without them
before and it's well documented as jake
paul clearly stated in the video that
his dad isn't allowed in america so
we've known this is he can't come here
he just can't i don't know what's going
on with his brother but it doesn't
really matter it's just an excuse for
tommy fury not to fight jake paul i
think it's pretty evident that tommy
fury just doesn't want this fight or
maybe he does but what i think is just
speculation what i think is going on is
the fury family looked at jake paul in
his skill set and said uh son this isn't
for you you're gonna give the whole
family name a bad look by getting
knocked out by jake paul because that's
exactly what would happen if you look at
what jake paul agreed to it's insane two
million dollar purse now let's talk
about two million dollar purse two
million dollar purse tommy fury will
never touch two million dollars inside a
boxing ring ever i don't think it's ever
possible for that man to ever get a two
million dollar bag based off uh his
record his experience you'd have to
fight for i don't know probably win the
next 10 fights by knockout in order to
even smell two million dollars it's a
perfect opportunity for tommy fury to
make a lot of money boxing a youtuber
so for tommy fury i think his family's
going hey we have all the money
his brother has all the money his dad's
doing fine although he can't come to the
states so he's not doing that great but
you know so his family and their legacy
they're going hey we'll give you a two
million just not to take the fight this
is a terrible look my man she's not win
the fight it's not happening because if
you look at tommy fury's boxing record
it is
awful now it's not awful that he's
undefeated it's off on the opponents
that he has fought
some could argue that jake paul has a
much tougher uh
boxing
opponents by far than tommy fury it's
not even close
what you want me to look into it okay
i'll do that real quick for you so his
last fight which he won against daniel
bokonovsky mike with kenowski his last
fight he thought he was 10 and two
you're like oh that's not bad yeah it's
not bad except for that guy who's 10-2
is coming off a loss and his fight
before that he beat a guy by decision
who's 11 and 37.
11 37. but tommy beat him okay sure but
it wasn't an easy fight for him and
before that he fought a guy in anthony
taylor who was on one and he won by
decision and before that he fought a guy
named jordan grant who's 2-0 okay he
beat him by decision uh before that he
fought a guy who's 0-9 he knocked him
out you guys
never had success in the boxing ring
before they fought a guy who who's own
11 before that he uh tko guy who's two
and 26
and then this is where it gets really
dicey his first two fights he fought a
gentleman who's owen 26 and then this is
my ultimate favor favorite and this guy
would love to have on the show on a food
truck if he wants this man is 10 and
102.
10 102.
maybe boxing's not for you but god bless
you my man you keep on doing it so tommy
fury's resume is
terrible and if you look at jake paul's
it's much more impressive so who
doesn't want to fight who clearly tommy
fury does not want this fight the second
time he pulled out first time pulled out
due to an illness whatever then he
agrees to the fight and jake paul agreed
to every single thing matter of fact
jake paul goes dude you can't have your
corner how about this i won't have my
corner i'll do it solo dolo he's just
trying to get a fight so if you guys are
sitting watching this right now going
yeah but jake paul's not a real fighter
but tommy fury is in what world cuz his
brother
no come on there's no argument there
also for the argument of well jake fall
hasn't jake paul hasn't fought a real
boxer does tommy fury check that box for
you he doesn't for me
i think uh woodley's a much more
difficult opponent than tommy fury it's
not even close
so to me this is a matter of tommy
fury's family going we've seen the tape
man we've also seen you fight let's go
uh can you go back to love island i
don't think so i don't know how it works
i think you only do one round but if you
could let's do that but you can't do
that so i think they're looking at us
going
you're going to lose this fight it's
going to be a huge black guy no pun
intended a huge black guy in the fury
family name
it's not happening let's pull out and if
you look at the press conference tommy
fears a shy
nice kid super shy his dad john did all
the trash talking so his dad became this
bigger than life celebrity who talked
all this [ __ ] to a youtuber and jake
paul and tommy just sat on the side it's
a bad look i think his family goes
listen this isn't good for the family
let's back out of it
and it's insane because tommy fury's
talked all this trash jake paul's agreed
to every single thing to make this fight
happen and you get two million dollars
find that madison square garden what
more could you want tommy fury here's
the other thing you never knew this
opportunity again never because recently
dana went on the mack life dana white
and said
yeah listen
when it comes to nate diaz and he's
being respectful but also throwing a
little shade said when it comes to nate
diaz it's not like we're talking about
kamal who's been here the guy's won one
fight in the past six years you know so
we do oma fight and we're trying to you
know honor that the contract but he
really should be fighting jake paul
release them dana
release them your move uncle dana
release nate diaz so he can move on and
fight jake paul and make so much more
money and that's what he wants even
tweet out all right send the release
papers
i would be willing to bet the ufc might
be down to do that although they're just
waiting to see what connor wants to do
because that's their cash cow so if
conor goes no don't let him off yet i
don't know if i'm in december or january
you're not going to get a nate diaz
release but if connor goes now i'ma
fight michael chandler or charles
oliveira i bet you the ufc actually is
open to releasing ideas so again
your move uncle dana how about you let
nate diaz go so he can move on and jake
paul
he needs somebody to tango with and this
is a huge fight for both of them to make
all the money but dana just released our
boy nate diaz can you do that for us
your move my man
you